this is some white pill good news people
are waking up to this stuff crazy dave
rubin
and his crazy crew of youtube blaze tv
locals viewers have imparted some wisdom
on the masses it's possible because
people are starting to realize that the
federal government is too powerful and
doesn't do much good so we've got some
info this is a new gallup poll a quote
from blaze media a new survey from
gallup finds that most americans have
reverted to thinking the government
should have a more limited role last
september when the nation was firmly in
the grips of the coronavirus pandemic
with states locked down businesses
closed and racial unrest dominating
headlines
a record high 54 percent of u.s adults
surveyed by gallup said the government
should do more to solve problems but in
the year since then president joe biden
took office and started a massive
expansion of the federal government's
role in the pandemic response on
constitutional executive orders vaccine
mandates 1.9
million uh trillion dollar stimulus bill
one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
and a 3.5 bill back better spending bill
now gallup finds that 52 of americans
say the government is doing too many
things that should be left to the
individuals and businesses while 43
say the government needs to do more to
solve problems so we're going to throw
this image up for just a second the key
part that you have to look at there is
that the blue line which is that the
government should do more to solve
problems if you look just right at the
end there it was peaking it was peaking
basically
in 2020 we were all freaked out we
wanted the government to do stuff well
now it's dumping out we're realizing the
government doesn't do much well and the
green line which says the government's
trying to do too many things well that
jumped from 41 about a year ago to 52
now this is a great sign this is the
type of sign that we have needed to see
that people are realizing it's your life
the machine doesn't really work it
doesn't really care about you it wants
to control you they flaunt their own
rules joe biden at a restaurant in dc
this week you can keep giving them your
money and getting less and less for it
or you can start thinking about your
life seriously try to figure out ways uh
to flourish without
needing these ridiculous buffoons